Dagny, we met when you were 103 years old.
And we talked about your long life.
Please come closer.
We met when you were 103, and we talked about your long life.
And I was unsure if I would meet you again.
Yes.
But, imagine, you're sitting here now, and you're 106!
Yes. And I'm almost uninjured!
Almost uninjured!
It was a close call this time ...
You were hit by a car last week.
I was almost home, ten steps away ...
... in the pedestrian crossing ...
... on my way up to the sidewalk ...
... when a girl came with her car, and she was probably on her mobile phone ...
... probably telling someone that she was almost home.
And she drove straight into me, and I flew ...
... first on top of one side of the car and then down again on the other.
Were you ...
Did you break anything?
I only broke my pinky finger!
And then your arm ...
Yes. And then I've got some bruises on my forehead.
But what was it like going to the hospital?
You haven't spent a lot of time in the hospital.
That's perfectly fine, you're like a princess there!
Okay? What ..?
The food could be a little better.
What's the problem with the food?
It gets transported long distances, so it's cold when it arrives!
And I've always imagined that warm food should be warm and cold food should be cold!
Not everything should be served cold.
You don't find being at a hospital boring?
No, there's almost too much happening there, it should be more calm!
They do tests and give medicines in the middle of the night, one can't sleep!
You're still living quite an active life.
Not just as a blogger, but you've become a public person.
Yes.
Have you been able to ...
... follow through with your appointments?
You've been at the hospital and at the same time had a premiere of your documentary ...
I mean, you couldn't be a part of your premiere?
Yes, I went to the premiere!
But I didn't drink champagne because I was on medicine.
I'm thinking ... Since the last time I met you ...
... a lot has happened in your life.
Yes, for sure. It wasn't as much fun in the beginning, but it gets better towards the end!
I'm not really sure why they selected me.
Or how they found me.
But I was blogging.
There were almost no near-100-year-olds who were blogging, they thought I was really crazy!
But ...
But I write well, I actually do.
Yes. And a lot of people follow your blog.
Proper Swedish, which I learnt in school.
You write much better Swedish than I do, I'll give you that!
You shouldn't be embarrassed about that, you're not really Swedish.
Jonas and I were talking about ...
... preparing for when you leave this earth.
I don't want to think about death, it's the saddest thing in this world.
I'll live for today and tomorrow, I know nothing about when I'll die.
Didn't you think that you were about to die when your husband died?
Yes.
Yes, I thought that was so sad and miserable, and I felt sorry for both myself and the entire world.
But when I didn't die, I was forced to start living!
You can't just walk around and whine, you have to get a grip of your existence!
I was actually very wealthy, I had several millions.
I gave it to a cancer fund.
And I saved a little for the funeral.
And I got an old computer, it was quite a blessing.
I'm thinking about, Dagny, that when you're born in 1912 ...
... you've been witness to women getting the right to vote.
Yes.
But women weren't very appreciated before in the world.
They were supposed to take care of their husband, children and household. And then ...
... they were supposed to be content, and best case they would also get a little pocket money.
May I say a little something?
Because there you are ...
Your generation is the first generation of women who actually ...
... have been allowed to vote.
Yes!
And who have been able to educate themselves and to work.
And that's fantastic!
But the worst thing when I was a child, was that ...
... education cost money.
If I had been able to study after going to school, I would have become a professor, at least!
My mother was born in 1926.
And ...
They took her and her two sisters to the doctor ...
... who measured their heads and spoke a little to them, and ...
... talked to them about what they could become.
And they could choose between school teacher ...
... secretary ...
... or nurse.
And do you know what my mother did?
No.
She agreed to be a school teacher.
She went down to the institute in Göteborg.
And she said: «I'm not a man nor a woman, I'm a school teacher!»
She left there, never came back, and said: «I need to be free».
And when I listen to you ...
I feel like you've arrived at this «I need to be free».
Yes.
Awesome! Excuse me! I will now return.
I'm rooting for you!
Before we finish, I just have to ask you ...
What has the doctor said, how long do you have to wear the bandages?
For three weeks.
Three weeks?
Yes.
Impractical.
Yes. It's unpleasant.
But it's a good defense weapon!
Dagny, thank you so much!